big birds such as geese cranes and
ibises tend to fly in V formations the
aerodynamics of the flight patterns have
fascinated biologists and aircraft
designers for decades to take a more
detailed look at the birds flight
scientists studied Northern bald ibises
from zoo Vienna these birds aren't going
to be on exhibit but are to be released
into the wild to teach the birds a
migration route to Italy volunteers
wrote in the back of a microlight plane
and shouted for the youngsters to follow
the birds were equipment that recorded
their exact position and every wing beat
for 43 minutes the recording equipment
showed that the birds can time their
wing beats so their wingtips either
match the path taken by the wing
movement of the bird in front of them or
is deliberately out of phase with it
whether the bird's wings were in sync or
out of sync dependent on their alignment
with the birds in front of them when
flying diagonally behind another bird in
the V formation the birds tended to
match the path of the front fliers
linked it as a result the trailing bird
gains lick from the one in front of it
but when one bird was directly behind
another one flying with wings out of
phase was best the position reduces the
large downwash of air pushed down by the
front flier the results were published
january fifteenth in nature they are the
first to record the complex wing
flapping coordination pattern of free
flying birds